all right guys bang bang I've got Darius
here with me Darius I thought a great
place to start Q4 in this conversation
is the weather model that you all put
together it should give us a sense of
where we are in markets and potentially
where we're headed what exactly is this
model saying that you guys have
constructed yeah absolutely thanks for
having me again always a pleasure so
I'll start in terms of explaining what
the hell this thing is uh this is one of
the most powerful tools we built at 42
macro to sort of help us understand and
really manage our position sizing around
the various asset classes and so I I
thought it would be helpful to kind of
run down each of the 10 principal
components of macro and how they are
independently contributing to each of
those weather model signals that you're
seeing there in the middle of the page
so we'll start with the top left we have
growth is accelerating here in the US
economy on a trend basis is expected to
Trend lower over the next 12 months at
least according to consensus Wall Street
uh estimates uh when you look at
inflation it's been trending lower it's
expected to turn low over the next 12
months albe it although we may see some
um some surprises thrown into the wrench
uh here on Wednesday in terms of PPI and
CPI on Thursday in terms of employment
the unemployment rate is trending higher
it's expected to Trend higher over the
next 12 months in terms of sales and and
earnings growth estimates for the S&P
sales growth are trending lower and
earnings growth estimates are trending
higher in terms of fiscal policy The
Sovereign fiscal balance as a percent of
GDP has been trending lower I.E the
budget deficit is getting wider that
minus 8.5% there in terms of the
previous value was a record non-war non-
recession budget deficit in the US
economy uh despite the you know the
fiscal pracy that we continue to see
down in DC uh the US dollar is trending
higher on a real effective exchange rate
basis and that's been weighing on
liquidity as we can see in the top right
uh so if you look at our 42 macro net
liquidity model which is the Fed balance
sheet minus the treasury general account
and the reverse up facility balance that
number's been trending lower our Global
liquidity proxy is also trending lower
that balances the uh Global central bank
balance sheet plus global broad money
supply plus global FX reserves minus
gold in terms of credit we're also
seeing private sector liquidity Trend
lower as well so credit growth is
trending lower both domestically and
globally uh if you look at interest
rates Benchmark policy rates are
trending higher globally uh the two-year
nominal yield spread relative to that
Benchmark policy rate is trending lower
and is a negative value so not only do
investors expect the FED uh to start
cutting in terms of the short to
intermediate term time Horizon that
number has actually gotten lower in
recent months and then lastly we
aggregate positioning across the US
dollar US rates Commodities and equities
and terms of the dollar it's all the
major currencies and gold and right now
the dollar is at an extreme bullish
signal uh in terms of its aggregated
positioning us rates us treasuries are
an extreme bearish signal as our
Commodities and equities are finally
neutral and have been for a little bit
of a while but primarily they've been
bearish throughout
2023 now I see in the model that you
have conviction medium and help people
understand like what would change your
conviction from medium to high in this
scenario yeah so that's a great question
so right now we are in a Goldilocks
regime if you focus on those top two uh
top left two uh boxes where we have
growth and inflation which help us
identify what the bottomup grid regime
is in the US economy right now we're in
Goldilocks because growth is
accelerating and inflation is
decelerating on a realized basis uh the
reason it's a medium conviction
Goldilocks regime is because only one of
those components is actually confirming
the current Trend I.E inflation is
expected to continue trending low over
the next 12 months whereas growth is
expected to inflect lower at some point
in the next 12 months and Trend lower
and so that's where we get a medium
conviction it would be high conviction
if both growth and inflation estimates
were confirming the current Trend it
would be a low conviction regime uh if
growth and inflation estimates were
disconfirming the current Trend so right
now you know that Medium conviction uh
Goldilocks regime is likely headed to
something that looks like a low
conviction or potentially even a full
regime change and we would expect it to
change uh in Q4 because we don't expect
growth at least our other models are
suggesting that growth is likely to
inflect lower and decelerate so we could
very much be in a high conviction
deflation regime at some point in the
next three to four months maybe with a
cup of coffee and inflation um but we'll
see now one of the big stories obviously
going into Q4 uh that no one expected at
the end of Q3 uh is the conflict that's
happening in Israel um when you see
geopolitical conflict like this kick off
we saw obviously Russia Ukraine now
we're seeing uh this in Israel what are
the things investors should be paying
attention to Are there specific metrics
or certain part of the market that you
immediately say if I want to understand
the impact on financial markets I go
check X yeah great question so I'll
start in terms of the Leading Edge of
that process it's going to come through
market-based signals and ultimately find
its way into sort of more economic uh
data signals like the ones that we just
discussed here so I'll start with the
market signals and then I'll I'll I'll
end with the uh the economic signals
Market signaling you always want to uh
be measuring for regime change
particularly when you're coming off of a
risk on regime as if as we were for
primarily really since going back to to
April we've been in a risk-on regime uh
we are now flirting with a risk-off
regime we'll see if it holds uh here but
if we do Transition to a risk-off regime
what that ultimately means is that the
trend in volatility is going to be
rising across asset classes you're going
to see things like credit spreads break
out you're going to see things like the
move index currency volatility uh start
to break out you're going to see dollar
strength and ultimately you're likely to
see an inverse correlation between
stocks and bonds particularly if it's a
real you know kind of negative riskof a
market event
although that's not always the case but
generally speaking that's kind of that's
kind of what we've experienced for the
past few decades um in terms of the
economic signals it's everything that
we're talking about on this page so we
as Talking Heads we as investors people
who spend all day on Twitter and
listening to podcast we're all listening
for things that ultimately are
represented here on this page on in
terms of our weather model you know
there's nothing more important as an
investor to identify what the trends are
in growth inflation employment profits
policy credit interest rates position
these are the things that you need to
make sure you're paying attention to day
after day week after week month after
month as an investor and right now the
current constellation of those signals
which each in contribute independently
to each of those asset class projections
in the middle of the page are saying hey
look you should as an investor expect
below normal returns for the stock
market over the next three months you
should expect normal returns for the
bond market over the next three months
normal returns for the US dollar over
the next three months and below normal
returns for commodities and Bitcoin over
the next three months at least according
to how all these major contributing
factors to asset Market dispersion are
currently
aligned when you see this specific uh
region um it's a little bit different I
think than obviously Russia Ukraine
where Russia uh and the Ukraine region
is responsible for tons of uh oil tons
of natural gas wheat you know you can
kind of go through all these Commodities
and very very heavy trading partner not
only for the United States but other uh
areas around the world um Israel has
importance for other reasons right they
don't necessarily have massive exports
of uh these Commodities does that change
some of the way that investors should
look at this or uh maybe even the way
that uh markets will move because uh it
may have geopolitical importance um but
it doesn't necessarily have the
commodity importance that the Russia
Ukraine region had yeah that's a great
question um so it in isolation Israel
does not have the importance as it
relates to Commodities but in in terms
of the geopolitical importance it's much
higher than Ukraine uh we are official
Partners in and and you know with with
the country like Israel in terms of us
so it's very easy to see the US dragged
into a proxy war much more so than you
could expect that that outcome to occur
in terms of Ukraine and NATO and one
final thing I'll say on in terms of this
current conflict in Israel obviously the
the the real the real risk here is that
Iran is somehow you know pulling the
strings here they they've obviously vly
denied any involvement in the terrorist
attack this this pre this past weekend
but if it terms out in future you know
in subsequent months we could also see
Iranian barrels of crew taking off the
market we could see anyone who's
friendly with Iran going forward in
terms of sanctions see their crw
incrementally taken off the market and
that's those are things that could
obviously weigh on on energy Supply and
one final thing I'll say on energy
Supply is that we are in a much more
precarious position now as investors and
human beings um in terms of where we are
in terms of energy Supply relative to
where we were uh when Putin invaded
Ukraine and the reason I say that is
because we are now at record production
for the US economy on record efficiency
in terms of crude oil production you
know we have almost the lowest rig count
we've ever seen even though we're at the
highest level of production that we've
ever seen moreover we are you know we're
basically back at 1970 type levels of
the spr inventories you know we with
obviously President Biden you know you
know basically cutting that thing more
in more than in half in you know last
year when they were buying votes ahead
of the midterm so you know there's not a
lot of interest you know the incremental
barrels of crude oil are going to be
very difficult to obtain if we get into
a situation over the next few weeks and
months where we are in fact taking
barrels of incremental barrels of Supply
offline from sanctions or
otherwise now my last question is uh
Paul tutor Jones recently went on uh
CNBC and he was talking about uh this
may be the most stressful complex
geopolitical threat uh environment that
we have seen we have Russia Ukraine we
now have Israel uh and likely at some
point we will have China Taiwan as well
um his point was not only is it complex
and obviously going to be very difficult
we need leadership and kind of all the
things that are necessary for Solutions
but it is happening at the exact same
time that the United States is fiscally
in the worst you know situation that it
has been in in years if not decades how
does the impact of our response end up
leading to national debt interest rate
Decisions by the Central Bank you know
some of these things that people may not
immediately connect from an investment
standpoint but it's very obvious seeing
even just Russia Ukraine there's going
to be impacts on debt interest rate
decisions Etc yeah 100% that's a
fantastic question my friend you always
you always asks the best questions man
so I'll start by saying the reason Paul
tutor Jones hasn't seen an environment
like this is because the last
environment that we had like this was
the previous fourth turning we are
currently in a fourth turning and based
on the the work from my former colleague
Neil how and his former partner Bill
Strauss I would say Darius Dell 42 macro
is probably the number three person on
that list of leading the charge on
Fourth research across the globe I would
certainly put myself up there in that
category we know that things like Total
War are very high probability in a
fourth turning not just Total War here
in the US but Total War globally we've
seen that se on several occasions uh we
also know that um The Sovereign budget
balance uh tends to deteriorate sharply
in Forth turnings we also know that as a
function of that we tend to see a big
spike in sovereign debt and so what's
very likely is that as we continue to
find ourselves engaged in these proxy
wars and maybe even in our own War
physical war total war here in terms of
the US you know whether it be China
Taiwan or some other thing that that's
yet to be foreseen we know where the
budget deficit and debt are going and
and I'd say very very much take the over
on CBO projections take the over on Paul
tutor Jones projections take the over on
anyone's projections Because unless
they've seen the empirical analysis that
we put out in our most recent macro
scouting reports about the fourth
turning they have no idea where this is
all headed and it's ultimately headed to
a place that's going to take us policy
to a level that we have not seen as it
relates to you know the B the the
financial repression and the currency
debasement that many bitcoiners and many
folks who watch your program um you know
kind of expect I would say expect way
more based on the empirical analysis
that we've that we've U that we've
performed in that in this particular
topic so ptj is right it's going to get
worse unfortunately uh we have probably
another decade at least of this these
types of Dynamics deteriorating from
here um you know in terms of the you
know the work the most recent book that
my former colleague Neil how put out out
in terms of the fort turning is here and
the one thing I'll say is that as an
investor this is going to be a very
difficult time to manage risk in there's
going to be more volatility we
ultimately know bitcoin's going to go
through the moon stock market's going to
go through the moon as a function of the
policy response to monetize these
Sovereign debts and deficits but it's
going to be a very volatile thumpy ride
and if you don't have a you know macro
risk manager or someone who's good at
actually you know managing risk in
financial markets to help you take
advantage of those big moves then God
bless you that makes of sense to me
where can weit say people to find you on
the internet or learn more about 42
macro yeah I mean at the bare minimum
definitely come check out our fourth
turning analysis I think a lot of what
we do um is probably over the head for
your median you know audience member but
at the bare minimum I think everyone in
the world needs to see that like 40
slides of information in terms of the
empirical Deep dive study that we put
out on the fourth turning so I highly
recommend everyone U definitely check
out our most recent uh a couple macros
scotting reports uh and then obviously
42 macro.com is our website definitely
check me out on Twitter as well derale
42 is my handle amazing Darius as always
I learn something new every single time
so I appreciate it we'll talk again soon
appreciate you P thank you brother